tactical village day is awesome we get
to field-test a bunch of cool new
weapons and there's always a new
training situation last year's was
Prison Break
it got super violent it's like being in
an action movie it's also a good
opportunity for us to let off steam and
bond as a unit everybody gets into it
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
say the nine-nine has never had a
perfect run
I need somebody throw out a lineup will
you be scary Terry scary Terry he says
what regular Terry's thinking why are
you up so early no reason just excited
to face a new day oh because ever since
we've been down here you've been a
little depressed have I tell me the
burrito I've wanted to build a rapport
with him since he got here but until now
all we've had in common was our bank
guess who
Stevie and I were beat cops together we
called ourselves the beatsie boys and
yeah it was as cool as it sounds so
y'all would just stand around like that
are you trying to Monty Hall me it's
unbelievable
I don't need Monty Hall ruining my place
of work with Monty Hall has already
ruined my home life come on sir the math
thing isn't the problem night shifts
keeping you and Kevin apart you two just
need a bone
I said you two need a bone Oh dare you
detective Diaz I am your superior
officer Wow what happens in my bedroom
detective is none of your business
don't ever speak to me like that again
god I missed this place let me just soak
it in
oh yeah stale coffee finger printing ink
whatever Charles is fermenting in his
desk beans beans it's like I never left
all right fill me and tell me everything
I missed won't take long only three
things happened Terry chipped his tooth
and had a list for a week
listen up even number two Santiago and
Boyle wore the same outfit to work one
day I just did the better on you and
captain ban headphones from the office
due to the Gina incident great recap no
one listens to me I'm a lousy sergeant
what no don't say that why would you say
that if I tell you something you promise
not to tell anyone else of course you
know how I took the lieutenant's exam
last week I just found out I didn't pass
oh no oh but you shouldn't feel bad only
like 10% of people pass on the first try
I know and I'm all exhausted because of
the night shift plus my bathroom break
during a test took a little longer than
anticipated yeah he's a restroom please
[Music]
nothing to see yeah excuse me
little desk that's why they say it's
test time so diaper up they say that
I've never said that I've never worn a
diaper during a test it would wear a
diaper during it does hey Boyle now you
have enough Peralta as a secondary in a
while be careful it can be rough
hey saboteur that's not true I happen to
be a very good secondary so you were
just borrowing those cars account you
should ask him about his bank account
captain Santiago broke the glass Oh
Peralta
where have you been sorry I'm sorry I
know I am three T five minutes late
yikes but I had to stop and get some
wine hello good sir I'd like your finest
bottle of wine please
that will be $1,600 great I'd like your
$8 istel of wine please
it's from the finest vineyard in
Arkansas samesies we were doomed the
minute she slithered into the precinct
it's funny when we first met we had some
good times looks like we both want that
stapler seems that way based on what
happened so when did it all go south
1989 that was up for a big promotion
which would have fast-tracked my career
lunch offered to write a letter on my
behalf but instead she torpedoed me
because of something that happened the
night before she was to turn it in
Madeline would you care for a drink I'd
love one
I'm sure you can tell I'm quite drunk
I've had a couple that build up the
nerve I think we both know what I'm
about to say Raymond I don't think we
need to say anything
I'm gay that's what I was going to tell
you well then she sabotage my career
because I refused to bed her you wanted
to see me sir I understand you stopped
by the patrol offices morning briefing
yeah officer deetmore help me out with
my crime scene so I gave him a little
thank-you present hey deetmore
you're gonna bag evidence like a
five-year-old you should have the proper
tools - my first police kit the walkie
talkie blows bubbles hope you can handle
it we go take another crack at Whitman
giving in there like five times what are
you gonna do annoy him into talking haha
two three four
didn't work nice to see him like this
he's so confident this morning he
finally corrected the barista when she
caught him Charlize he's been living as
Charlize broil for five years it's great
it's also great he could take it down
just a smidge if you like pina coladas
good guy Charles sorry Terry
I'd like you to accompany me to a gun
range you mean Drive you there and wait
outside
far away from the guns I spent eight
years in the public affairs office so my
tactical skills are a little rusty I
need some pointers sorry I haven't found
a weapon since the incident the
mannequin incident I'm familiar actually
there was an incident after that another
incident Andy sir I may not be the man
for the job
let's go down he's embarrassed of me
last Christmas the classics department
threw a holiday party I had one drink
too many and utterly humiliated myself
and that was the point
st. Augustine was making in consolation
of philosophy yeah sounds super
humiliating Saints I'm smart smart I
confused st. Augustine with boëthius I
might as well have stepped on a rake and
bought myself before you the problem
wasn't what you said it was that Dean
Aleister pointed out your mistake and
you lost your damn mind
I misremembered it because I'm reading
both simultaneously one book is too big
for me
it was quite the kerfuffle I was
thinking we could liven things up in
there maybe add a model train I used to
love him when I was a kid I was also a
model train enthusiast as a child those
miniature tracks provided me with some
of my happiest memories all aboard the
train will be departing in 45 minutes
Peralta can I confess something to you I
didn't throw Frederick's duck in the
garbage
yes I know sir I didn't throw the duck
in the garbage
I threw it off a bridge just eaten
butter like a Pop's that go home Boyle
yeah I know I'm spoiling myself but I'm
depressed or have you forgotten that
Jake my best friend is in prison wait
Jake's in prison yeah he and Rosa were
framed for a bunch of bank robberies by
lieutenant Hawkins all right and where's
Gina on maternity leave we were all at
her baby shower last week okay and why
am i bleeding I don't know his god oh so
you don't have all the answers
I'm bleeding because my piece of crap
Sun a lot bit me
look we all miss Jake and Rosa which is
why we have to keep working a case there
has to be some way to exonerate him I've
been looking but I can't find anything
and I don't know what to do I can't find
anything and I don't know what to do
title of your sex tape what is happening
right now
they caught Hawkins trying to flee the
country she confessed to everything and
they let me out oh my god Jake is it
really you're really here you know it
baby
but first I got a hug my best friend
welcome back Peralta I just heard from
the mayor to apologize for what happened
to you they're sending you to Disney
World you and one male guest as long as
I don't have to go on any of the scary
rides I just go for the shows
Boyle were you dreaming about Jake again
why didn't you wake me up i jusu snap it
away for you
you